hello Facebook iron cat round I'm social
media at Glamour magazine and also today
feeling like the world's most successful
fantastic beast hunter juice
sketch of five and set the morning a
nice line next to Mauritania slip like
world's sexiest police lineup literally
nobody here requires an introduction so
I'll make it jolly speedy we have Eddie
Redmayne Katherine Waterston Dan Fogler
and Alison sudol and Ezra Miller they're
all as you know part of fantastic beasts
and where to find them which is
fantastic so we've got some questions
from fans on Facebook and Twitter but
first of all I wanted to just ask you
what what is it like to be joining
something of this scale I mean the Harry
Potter universe is obviously massive
with a huge fan base any trepidation
they're feeling pretty good what you
will think no we're awful what a
tradition very competent people he's
asking us like you know I are you ready
for you know your lives to change and
how do you feel about all the pressure
and all of us just start sweating this
morning we were okay told us about this
this part yeah I just ruined this entire
and it is amazing something that people
have been talking about quite a lot this
week is that the introduction of young
Dumbledore and just off the bat who
would you guys like to see taken take a
rolling stance on this a little bit that
if we say someone and then they don't
get it the person that does get its
gonna feel lousy they might just be a
surprise casting yeah oh well definitely
will be a surprise yeah you are us okay
we know anything we always know last and
so we are just we genuinely do not yeah
made an announcement on Twitter and I'll
be like oh got that Mary
I feel pretty good about Jared Harris
Paris from the crown I've been it's a
nice continuity if you're ever allowed a
free evening ever not say like an
encounter
kill that's never talking about wasn't
yeah and Ezer I'm going to start with
question from you from Brogan Wilson
mostly because your jacket is absolutely
stupendous the long coat and what do you
like that credence is costume I'll tell
you my favorite part which is sort of a
secret which is that I had a
conversation with Colleen Atwood who we
just have to say is a master and an
incredible human being and when I first
got there we were talking she like so
are you concerned at all she's a very
funny woman so she's like you know
seeing right through me she's like are
you worried at all about playing this
character and losing yourself in him and
I was like because I haven't thought
about it too much but yeah and and she's
like yeah yeah well be careful and then
when I got my costume I was out of
fitting when I got my costume
she had sewn into the inside of the back
of the jacket this really beautiful
symbol which had like a horse and an
eagle and there was a little message
that was from her just saying that she
you know this is to help you remember
yourself Oh weighing this character so
that's that was my favorite part of my
costume was this little thing that only
I came about that was that was re dances
it was it was mine it was a gift from
Colleen
you know we get into deep for the live
chat what a lovely thing to have ipera
ever allowed to actually get that code
again because that would be amazing
Steve fine playing real people or iconic
fictional characters more difficult um
other than but I was making birdsong in
Budapest and and it was a TV show John
it was first world war but jumping
between different periods and I thought
it was really tough and I remember the
director Tom Hooper was out there making
something else at the time and we had
lunch and he said I remember complaining
thinking you know this one's the hardest
and he turned to me is like yeah but
aren't they always the hardest and
basically any job you're doing but we're
thing about film is people think that
you have you could do hundreds of
different takes the reality is you only
have that that moment in that day to get
it right and then you go home in the car
at the end of the day and inevitably on
the way home you're like that idea
I see they just have to wait six months
to see the thing that you failed to do
up on the big screen so I feel like they
always feel the hardest but it's just a
question of how much fun you have within
it and so for this one it was liked all
the imaginary I have a really bad
imagination so like the imaginary CGI
things was quite complicated but it was
um by oh so much fun because I got a
hang with this bunch of reprobates
I was just awesome fifty items you got
out of there you won and I better have a
good education to be Eddie Redmayne and
be so self-deprecating that's a dream
stuff up to say that's bad about
yourself
I love this question from Michaela
Leffler who says I'd like all of your
patients you're always very friendly and
full of energy and on PR trips he wants
all the questions patiently even though
it's often the same questions again and
again and again now you ever think I
know this will come as a shock
do you ever think for God's sake I've
answered that same question at least
five times before PS I hope it's not the
fifth time that you hear this question
Wow bring that up yeah yeah I did
potentially out for four hours of
answering the same questions over and
over again answer one of my questions
while pouring a liter of water a wee
opiate will be released and go back it
was it was died out of absolute
necessity alive await but they usually I
feel like back in the day you'd be able
to just answer the same question you say
to the journalist on a junket oh good
question and then respond in exactly the
same way but then YouTube came along and
basically you can now bust me answering
exactly the same question in exactly the
same way about 5000 okay so you become a
living for source is what you do and and
you sort of think at different ways to
say fantastic wonderful fabulous great
immense salacious Eddie your brother Tom
introduced you to Harry Potter
alright yeah good yeah I'm sorry Oh his
reaction what was his reaction when you
got cast in fantastic beasts and that
would have been amazing um he was pretty
excited I've got to say no he was one of
the first people I told and he was he
was pretty pumped but he then kept
asking questions about the script and
about filming and we were sworn to such
Hulk or secrecy and we had the fear of
like my father's snipers like wherever
we yeah and he was like me and your
brother you're allowed to tell me I was
like you don't complicated yes so I
wouldn't even be here if we do see you
Larry
usually he'd get me drunk and then just
try and like fish secret side willing me
after a couple of years alcohol alcohol
okay and we've got a roughed-up very sad
oh one last one what is your favorite
magical creature and why hmm he's saying
that like he's stuck but he knows the
answer to this we have the same answer
yes si announcer pick it don't both
chuckles oh isn't it a little stick
insect any hugs and he has attachment
issues and he hugs I know you know
Halloween I like him cuz he's got like a
little bit of sass seems exciting and
sweet and huggy but if you wronged him
he he's like he's gonna stick it to you
yeah stick majority dick insect ik to
you yeah even if ler the NIF ler is this
like what did you call a porta push over
here I called him a porta puss
yeah definitely is a portable portable
is that a pouch and it's amazing he puts
all the shiny things in it peace man
well we're gonna have to keep that
battle going between these two team both
chuckle and Team Lafleur because that's
all we've got time for today but thank
you so much for speaking to us guys and
thank you so much for joining us all on
Facebook have a fantastic day - peace
play
so much close the Christmas preparation
Oh